vielen Dank herzlich willkommen zur
heute show meine Damen und Herren da
sind wir wieder und es ist wirklich
total verblüffend wie schnell sich bei
uns das Bild von Politikern dreht
überlegen Sie mal bis neulich war unser
Kanzler Olaf Scholz sowas wie der
Bremser von Europa der Zauderer der
alles auffällt jetzt seit dieser Woche
gilt er plötzlich als Mastermind als
weiser Yoda der Weltpolitik er hat uns
alle getäuscht meine Damen und Herren ja
von wegen isoliert Olaf Scholz hier
schmiedet die europäische panzerallianz
und befiehlt Joe Biden auch mitzumachen
ja am Ende war der deutsche Druck
einfach zu groß für die Amerikaner
historische Woche also und eine
historische Sitzung im Bundestag wo Olaf
Scholz von seiner ganzen Partei gefeiert
wurde also sagen wir mal von fast allen
das ist warum wir das so tun und so
werden wir es auch weitermachen
vielen Dank für die einleitenden Worte
und Herr Bundeskanzler wenn sie mich
beim nächsten Mal als sitzungsleitende
Präsidentin auch begrüßen werde ich sehr
dankbar
hui
hör mal warum ist Bärbel was nicht
Verteidigungsministerin geworden ne
den Ton hat sie drauf können sie nicht
grüßen
Deutschland schickt jetzt also doch 14
moderne Leopard Panzer also sogar welche
von den guten nicht den Schrott nachdem
wir die Geduld unserer internationalen
Partner sehr lange strapaziert haben mit
einer gewissen scholzigen ja sagen wir
mal Bockigkeit ne ja
so ist das beim Olaf ne wenn Ihnen alle
drängen dann will er erst recht nicht
vor allem will er uns seine Politik
nicht erklären wieso absolute Zumutung
weil was geht uns als Bürger denn seine
Ukraine Strategie an warum haben sie die
nicht zwischendrin den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern und uns allen erklärt habe ich
hast du nicht
man könnte zum Beispiel mal vor der
Lieferung von Leopard Panzern den
Bürgern erklären warum wir die dahin
schicken erklären was ist das Ziel soll
die Ukraine am Ende gewinnen ist ein
Satz den Olaf hier bis heute nicht über
die Lippen kriegt dann geht's wohl nicht
ohne Kampfpanzer sagen Experten die
Polen und andere sprechen das aus warum
auch nicht warum auch nicht aber klar
brutal nein es sind brutal schwierige
Abwägungen die getroffen werden müssen
und die jeder von uns hat Angst vor dem
Atomkrieg nur wenn wir uns von den
nuklearen Drohungen dieses terrorstaats
wirklich leiten lassen dann müssen wir
die Ukraine heute noch fallen lassen
danach Moldau und dann das Baltikum denn
Putins Regime hat noch große Pläne wie
sein lieblingsmoderator verrät
Schulz gehört
[Musik]
Moment habe ich das jetzt richtig
verstanden die Russen würden uns Berlin
abnehmen also
das wäre natürlich ein Traum muss ich
sagen
da lege ich noch Brandenburg oben drauf
nach einem Jahr verpennter zeitenwände
soll nun also alles besser werden mit
unserem neuen Verteidigungsminister denn
Olaf Scholz hurra hat am Ende doch noch
einen freiwilligen gefunden für diesen
Höllen Job ja war nicht so einfach
will ja kein normaler Mensch machen wenn
Lars Klingbeil hat direkt abgesagt wegen
Rücken
Hubertus Heil ist nicht mehr ans Telefon
gegangen und als Scholz zur
werbeauftragten Eva Högl ins Büro
gegangen ist war die irgendwie nicht da
ist komisch
mysteriös dafür und das ist die gute
Nachricht ist es jetzt kein geringerer
als der ehemalige Minister für Inneres
und Sport aus Niedersachsen Boris
Pistorius kennen Sie den hier das heute
schon Bilderrätsel
in diesem Bild hat sich ein neuer
Verteidigungsminister versteckt
war zu schwer letzte Woche Montag hat
das am Telefon von Olaf Scholz erfahren
und war selber überrascht er hatte nicht
mit sich gerechnet tatsächlich ist der
Pistorius aber eine top-verpflichtung
sagen auch alle Kollegen über den
Pistorius weil ich erlebe Prätorius in
der parlamentarischen Gesellschaft der
NATO Verteidigungsminister Boris jetzt
ist es ja Prätorius wir wünschen ihm
alles Glück was er braucht ja und da
schließen wir uns natürlich gerne an
alles Gute fürs neue Amt lieber Oskar
relotius
ja komm ich finde es keine schlechte
Wahl er hat Regierungserfahrung wenn
auch nur in Hannover er spricht Klartext
und ganz wichtig der Mann hat gedient
Pistorius war beim Bund 1981 wird jetzt
überall als Qualifikation erwähnt und da
ist ja was dran meine so vieles was man
beim Bund lernt
kann man später Ministerium eins zu eins
anwenden tatsächlich ist so wenn du
unseren Ministerium rein guckst du
siehst sofort wer von den gedient hat
Moment richtig der hier
[Applaus]
und ich Idiot hab zivildiendienst
gemacht
ja ich finde sei mal mal dankbar dass
der Boris den Job machen will ist eine
absolute Herkulesaufgabe zur Erinnerung
die Bundeswehr hat nur noch für zwei
Kampftage am Stück Munition er muss die
unreformierbare Beschaffung reformieren
und ohne Ende Bürokratie abbauen echt
nicht zu beneiden der Mann aber er kommt
wohl gut an bei der Truppe was jetzt
nach Christine Lambrecht nicht so schwer
ist aber immerhin ne er trifft den
richtigen Ton und er erteilt erstmal
Aufträge die die man schaffen kann
deswegen habe ich heute morgen meinem
Haus den Auftrag erteilt eine Prüfung
vorzunehmen über die Bestände von
Leopard Panzern der verschiedenen Typen
habe ich das richtig verstanden der
lässt jetzt echt unsere Panzer zählen
also ich bin nicht vom Fach aber kurze
Frage warum muss das nachgezählt werden
haben die noch nie Inventur gemacht oder
was meine Edeka weiß doch auch wie viel
hanuta noch im Regal liegen
denkt man aber so einfach ist es nicht
Freunde und das kennt jeder aus der
eigene Garage wo habe ich den Leo jetzt
wieder hingestellt da ist er hinter dem
Fitnessgerät ne
einer wird immer gerade bei Bares für
rares vertickt und einen hat Christine
Lamprecht ihrem Sohn zum bestandenen
Führerschein geschenkt ja
den kann man dem jungen jetzt nicht
wieder wegnehmen das wäre gemein alles
spannend oder es ist so spannend wie
viele Panzer haben wir die genaue Zahl
wird noch ermittelt sie zählen noch
sicher ist seit dieser Woche sind es 14
weniger ist gut für die Ukraine aber
möglicherweise ein weiteres Problem für
unsere gebeutelte Bundeswehr meine wir
haben ja schließlich auch noch NATO
Verpflichtungen für die nächsten Jahre
wie läuft's da so 86 Raketenwerfer
werden benötigt nur 35 sind vorhanden
die Bundeswehr benötigt ab
2027-160 neue rathausitzen Bestand null
ja ich habe das für Sie direkt mal
ausgerechnet die Differenz beträgt 160
er ist ein großes Problem Beispiel die
Panzerhaubitzen die wir der Ukraine
spendiert haben wurden für den Bund bis
jetzt nicht nachbestellt warum auch
immer weiß keiner mancher Experten
fordern jetzt schon Deutschland müsste
insgesamt umstellen auf Kriegswirtschaft
bzw es ist Kriegswirtschaft das hieße
sämtliche Firmen von Siemens bis also
nicht Haribo produzieren dann nur noch
Patronen und sowas und das ZDF muss auch
alles neu denken ist ja klar machen wir
auch aus dem Traumschiff machen wir die
Traum Fregatte aus wetten das wird
Wetten Don Bass für Kinder läuft die
Drohne Maja was sonst und abends
selbstverständlich Markus Lanzer der
gibt sich von selbst
ja der Name hat bei den älteren
Zuschauern viel besser getestet also die
Bundeswehr schickt 14 Leos Richtung
Ukraine und wir schalten mal live zum
Truppenübungsplatz Oberlausitz zu mallor
Holger Stockhaus her mallor die Panzer
kommen aus Zitat Beständen des Heeres
was heißt das für ihre Arbeit
daher welke sagen wir mal so wenn ich
höre Bestände des Heeres dann würde ich
schon kurz zurückfragen welche Bestände
14 ist für uns ein astronomische zahl
ich weiß ja nicht ob schon mal 14 von
unseren Panzern gleichzeitig irgendwo
rumgefahren sind also nach 1945
natürlich
Kampftruppen liegt die
Einsatzbereitschaft aktuell bei
erbärmlichen 33 Prozent und wenn es mal
neue Geräte gibt dann passiert sowas
hier wie schlecht ist gleichzeitig um
die Ausstattung der Bundeswehr steht
wird am Panzer Puma deutlich bei einer
Übung der Bundeswehr waren zuletzt alle
18 Schützenpanzer mit technischen
Problemen ausgefallen
alle 18 im Arsch sofort wie war das denn
bitte möglich
unterschiedliche hochkomplexe Probleme
bei dem einen gab es wohl in Schwelbrand
am Kabelbaum den haben die Kameraden
spontan mit einem Pulverlöscher bekämpft
und jetzt muss leider der ganze Puma
auseinander gebaut werden um das
Löschpulver zu beseitigen wie gesagt ist
in einem Laien schwer zu erklären
mit anderen Worten ihr war zu doof und
hat alle 18 selber kaputt gemacht ja
macht aber nicht weil wir könnten die
Dinger eh nicht benutzen wie denn auch
ohne Munition
was muss sein
da tatsächlich haben wir nicht mal hier
noch Munitionslager die meisten wurden
aufgegeben auch blöd im Nachhinein auch
das Munitionsdepot in Hünxe in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ist nicht mehr
nutzbar die Bunker sind heute
Winterquartiere für Fledermäuse
ja und jetzt können wir die armen Tiere
schlecht wecken mitten im Winterschlaf
nee natürlich nicht natürlich nicht aber
warum kann man fehlende Sachen wie
Munition oder Panzer nicht einfach mal
rechtzeitig bestellen weil weiß ich
nicht Panzer scout24
na sie sind ja goldig einfach bestellen
Sachen da das hier ist immer noch
Deutschland hier gibt's Vorschriften sie
und ihr diente Liebe
das berühmteste ist dass eben die
Arbeitsstättenverordnung im Innenraum
eines Panzers gelten muss das heißt
Arbeitsplatzbedingungen wie sie auch
unter anderem für schwangere Frauen bei
einer acht-stündigen Büroarbeit gelten
müssen müssen auch im Panzer anwendbar
sein ja klar Arbeitsschutz ich muss zum
Beispiel in jedem neuen Leopard eine
Isofix Befestigung für den Maxi Cosi
haben alles nicht so einfach versuchen
Sie mal im Jahr 16 Wickeltisch
auszuklappen
ist bestimmt furchtbar sagen wie will
die Bundeswehr denn so bis 2025 die
versprochene neue Division mit 30.000
Mann zum Schutz der NATO Ostflanke auf
die Kette kriegen Jude Frage und wie
kommen wir dahin an die Ostflanke wir
haben erst überlegt mit Interrail
aber wenn man pünktlich zu seinem Krieg
kommen muss da ist die Bahn ja eher
suboptimal deshalb haben wir jetzt
Achtung unsere erste e-roller-brigade
aufgestellt bei gutem Wetter kommt man
auf den Dingern locker 10 12 km weit
damit rechnet der Russe nicht sehr gut
Männer sehr gut
ich glaube ich habe mein Roller kaputt
gemacht oh Gott Holger vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Sanierungsfall Bundeswehr
haben Sie wahrscheinlich gelesen schon
fordern die ersten Schlaumeier statt 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr 300 Milliarden kriegen wir
auch verballert oder oh und ich höre
gerade liebe Zuschauer es gibt schon
wieder neue dramatische Entwicklung
breaking news ja leck mich fährt jetzt
reicht's aber langsam wirklich Putin
enteignet wehrlosen deutschen Ölkonzern
ja meine Damen und Herren leider
wirklich war und diese Meldung ist so
ein bisschen untergegangen vor lauter
panzerstreit der größte deutsche
Mineralölkonzern wird von Putin de facto
enteignet kein Witz dazu begrüße ich
jetzt Valerie Niehaus Sprecherin von
Winter Salder
sie stehen wahrscheinlich immer noch
unter Schock oder
also super lieb dass sie fragen Herr weg
ist alles einfach nur noch traurig da
arbeitest du über Jahre bis gestern ja
eigentlich als deutsche Firma
vertrauensvoll mit dem pudding-regime
zusammen und dazu was
wir haben na ja ein extrem erfolgreiches
Joint Venture mit Gasform das geht
einfach nicht mehr
sie gehen raus aus moralischen Gründen
nehme ich an
moralisch das muss kurz Google nee nein
viel schlimmer nein die Russen haben
unser Geld eingefroren stellen sich das
doch mal vor wir haben im letzten Jahr
danke wir haben im letzten Jahr trotz
ukrainekrieg
unseren Gewinn in Russland vervielfacht
und dann friert er ihre Putin das ein
wir kommen nicht ran
okay nur damit ich das ist richtig
verstehe wintersall went das Teil ist
auch nach dem Überfall auf die Ukraine
als Partner von Gazprom drin geblieben
in Russland hat noch letztes Jahr
hunderte Millionen Steuern gezahlt
direkt in Putins Kriegskasse aber raus
geht ihr wegen Geld
was ja ich habe ich unterbreche sie nur
wenn sie was Falsches sagen was stimmt
alles also es stimmt also auch dass euer
Gaskondensat dass ihr der herstellt zu
Kerosin verarbeitet wird mit dem
wiederum russische Kampfjets die Ukraine
bombardieren das stimmt auch ja also nee
das ist ja nur völliger Bullshit also
das hat unser Unternehmen auch schon
alles Wesentliche dazu gesagt ne
das Gaskondensat in Sibirien werden noch
am Bohrloch an Gazprom übergeben mit der
weiteren Verwendung habe Wintershall
nichts zu tun
unheimlich wissen wir doch nicht was die
Russen mit dem Kerosin machen mit
Kerosin kannst du alles mögliche machen
viele Russen trinken das auch
komisch jetzt finde ich eure Verluste
plötzlich gar nicht mehr so traurig
welche Verluste oh Herr welke da haben
sie aber was furchtbar was verstanden
nein was das angeht fallen wir ja weich
also ich zitiere mal die schönsten Worte
die die deutsche Zunge kennt
bundesgarantien für direkt Investitionen
im Ausland also das ist reinste wo sie
für neue russland-projekte stellte
Wintershall einen Antrag auf Absicherung
dieser Investition in Höhe von rund 1,8
Milliarden Euro der damalige
Wirtschaftsminister Sigmar Gabriel
notiert handschriftlich ich unterstütze
den Antrag was ja aber warum ich meine
das war 2015 nach der Krim Annexion das
heißt eure Firma hat sich jahrelang dumm
und dämlich verdient in Putins Russland
und jetzt darf der deutsche Steuerzahler
euch retten wegen Sigma fucking Gabriel
erinnert der besten Minister die
Deutschland je hatte
Sigi wenn Katar oder die Deutsche Bank
dich irgendwann nicht mehr haben wollen
du hast immer einen Platz im
Aufsichtsrat von Wind
ich habe dich hier drin gesetzt das ist
alles so schlimm ich brauche dringend
ein Glas Kerosin Valerie Niehaus meine
Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
so meine Damen und Herren
[Musik]
mal eine ganz andere Frage was macht
eigentlich die Opposition in diesen
historischen Wochen die
opponiert wie sich das gehört ne unsere
Linkspartei zum Beispiel mit ihrer noch
Gallionsfigur Sarah Wagenknecht die
Sarah sie haben es wahrscheinlich
gelesen will sich ja bald mit einem
eigenen noch längeren Verein abspalten
ja
mach mal und sie ist seit neuestem wohl
auch poetry slammerin leider es gibt ja
diesen schönen Heine Spruch denke ich an
Deutschland der Nacht bin ich um den
Schlaf gebracht Schlaf gebracht und ich
muss sagen also denke ich an Deutschland
am Tag dann kommt mir der Schlag
und denke ich an die Wagenknecht wird
mir immer furchtbar schlecht das ist
also Scheiße dichten können wir alle sie
hat jetzt im Deutschlandfunk gefordert
der Westen müsste mehr Druck auf die
Ukraine machen damit die überfallenen
endlich verhandeln statt sich so
hartnäckig zu werden und übrigens schon
als Deutschland damals die peinlichen
5000 Helme geschickt hat twitterte die
Linke Fraktionschefin Amira Mohammed Ali
hier 5000 Schutzhelme ein fatales
Zeichen Schluss mit diesem Säbelrasseln
ja wie genau selbe rasselt man mit
Helmen habe ich mich gefragt
ist egal also damit wir uns richtig
verstehen ist es natürlich legitim immer
wieder Verhandlungen zu fordern aber man
darf ja nicht vergessen an wem echte
Verhandlungen scheitern an dem Mann der
jeden Tag auch sein eigenes Volk
verheizt das der Tod auf dem
Schlachtfeld keine tragödlich sein würde
das hat Vladimir Putin schon vor Wochen
den Müttern von Soldaten erzählt
die Frage ist doch jemand gelebt hat
manche sterben zu viel Wodka trinken so
der russische Präsident aber ihr Sohn
hat etwas erreicht er ist nicht umsonst
gestorben wow
also mehr Empathie geht wirklich nicht
immerhin hat ihr Sohn sind nicht tot
gesoffen sehen Sie mal das Positive ist
doch ekelhaft der will nicht verhandeln
der will die Ukraine als Staat weg haben
sollte die Linke mal drüber nachdenken
und dann ist dann natürlich noch der
Ultra rechte Flügel der neuen
Friedensbewegung richtig die AFD ja ich
rechne jetzt stündlich damit dass Alice
Weidel und Tino propala ihr erstes Bett
in für den Frieden veranstalten wie
damals John Lennon und Yoko Ono nee oh
Gott oh Gott oh Gott
eigentlich mehr ins Schlafzimmer das
Bild als Verhütungsmittel
auch die Alternative für Deutschland
warnt vor der sogenannten
eskalationsschraube ohne zu erwähnen
dass der original nur einer eskaliert
oder gibt es bei denen auch Kritik an
putin ist dieser Mann an
Kriegsverbrecher für mich ist ja kein
Kriegsverbrecher also Frau Zimmermann
hat gesagt putin ist ein Diktator und
ein Massenmörder das würden sie nicht
unterschreiben nein prima hätten wir das
doch auch geklärt ja schön diese Woche
hat der AFD Mann Peter büstrum im
Bundestag ernsthaft der SPD vorgeworfen
sie würde das Vermächtnis von Willy
Brandt mit Füßen treten die AFD als Fan
von Willy Brandt daraufhin ist der
Bronze William Willy brandt-haus vor Wut
vom Sockel gesprungen
zur afd-zentrale rüber gelaufen und hat
den vor die Tür gekackt
ja einen schönen brunchen
AFD ruft sie auf Willy Brandt gibt's
doch gar nicht so warte mal AFD hatten
wir Linkspartei haben wir noch
irgendeine relevante Opposition
vergessen richtig richtig die gibt's ja
auch noch die Union ohne die unsere
heutige Abhängigkeit von Russland so gar
nicht denkbar wäre über was meckern die
so nachdem Olaf Scholz jetzt sein
panzerkuh eingetütet hat vor zwei Tagen
in Paris was wäre das für ein Zeichen
gewesen gemeinsam mit dem französischen
Präsidenten diesen Vorschlag zu machen
oder vor vier Tagen in Ramstein ja oder
vor sechs Tagen in Oer-Erkenschwick nee
das ist jetzt die große CDU
Fundamentalkritik der diplomatische
Durchbruch kam zwei bis vier Tage zu
spät es ist halt muss man fairerweise
immer sagen auch nicht leicht als große
Oppositionspartei in Kriegszeiten und
dann auch noch mit einem Vorsitzenden
dessen Weltbild wie Sie wissen in den
90er Jahren eingefroren wurde Ötzi März
ja ja diese Woche genau diese Woche
einem Jahr ins Amt gewählt und sagen wir
mal so dass von ihm angeschobene Projekt
CDU Modernisierung läuft noch etwas
schleppend vielleicht auch wegen seiner
Interviews zum ukrainischen
sozialtourismus oder gelegentlicher
Pascha Pauschalisierung ein Jahr
Friedrich Merz Friedemann Weise gibt
Nachhilfe im Fach zeitgemäße
Parteiführung
neunte Stunde Nachsitzen bei Herrn Weise
heute Parteiführung
so Fritz da bist du ja endlich
Stau auf der Landebahn oder was also du
bist jetzt seit einem Jahr Parteichef
und ich sag mal viel zu feiern gibt es
da nicht okay deine Aufgabe war auch
nicht leicht ihr hattet ja schon große
Probleme in der Partei an wen ihr alles
Stimmen verloren habt sie hat auch
abgegeben im Rahmen des
Generationswechsels das heißt es sind
einfach mehr CDU Wähler gestorben als
Jungwähler hinzugekommen sind
Wählerwanderung ins Jenseits muss man
sich mal vorstellen die Leute wollen
lieber sterben als CDU wählen wenn euch
die Toten nicht wählen musst du halt
anders die Zielgruppen erweitern
Stichwort Frauen junge und Migranten
hast du doch selbst gesagt wenn wir
diese Gruppen nicht bekommen dann können
wir jede potentielle Mehrheit für die
CDU in Deutschland vergessen ja Frauen
junge und Migranten und du verscherst es
ja gerade mit einem gleichzeitig
Migranten deine Fraktion hat den
geringsten Anteil von Menschen mit
Migration diesem Hintergrund da ist
sogar die AFD drunter also wenn man
Reichsbürger als Migranten mitzählt und
Frauen du hast ja extra für die Quote
eine kommunikationschefin geholt die war
aber nach drei Monaten schon wieder weg
und wenn man dann mal nachfragt
reagierst du gleich immer so angefasst
haben sie ein Frauenproblem
also
Frau hasse ich habe auch sehr viele
Unterstützung gerade bei den Frauen
bekommen wenn ich meine Post richtig
lese dann sind das zur Hälfte mindestens
zur Hälfte Frauen die mir schreiben auch
ganz junge Frauen
ganz junge Frauen diese Mails kenne ich
Fritzchen lass dir mal deinen
Spam-Ordner richtig einstellen und bis
dahin auf keinen Fall irgendwas
anklicken verstanden ernsthaft warum
sollten dir junge Frauen schreiben wenn
ihr dich sehen wollen wissen die doch wo
man dich abends findet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Foxtrott Fritze auf der Suche nach dem
Beat aber du wolltest die CDU ja nicht
nur jünger machen du wolltest auch die
AFD Stimmen zurückholen hast du
großspurig angekündigt und dann traue
ich mir zu die AFD mit ihren Wählerinnen
und Wählern zu halbieren das geht
das geht ja schauen wir doch mal ob das
geht als du den Job angefangen hast lag
die AFD bei 11% und jetzt
15 Prozent nicht ganz halbiert aber ich
ahne was du vorhast du bringst sie rauf
auf 20 weil man das besser durch zwei
teilen kann
ob du überhaupt rechnen kannst du warst
ja ein richtiger Problem Jugendlicher
sitzen geblieben von der Schule geflogen
das ganze Programm heute müssen die
Kinder Fahrradhelme anziehen damals
hatten sie Frisuren aber das ist keine
Entschuldigung andere haben es trotz der
Frisur in der Politik weitergebracht als
du
einfach an deiner Herkunft woher kommst
du nochmal ich komme aus einer
ländlichen Region und wir haben dort
jetzt auch seit einiger Zeit wieder
freilebende visente
die auch in Konflikt geraten mit der
dortigen Bevölkerung mein Gott dann fahr
mal schnell zurück ins Sauerland und
kümmer dich nicht dass da wieder ein
paar Halbstarke wiesente an der
Bushaltestelle rumlungern ich habe jetzt
eh den nächsten Härtefall der hat gerade
rum erzählt er wird nie mehr
Kanzlerkandidat muss gar nicht so blöd
gucken Markus wir haben das besprochen
du wolltest weniger Lügen und jetzt
Handy weg sonst nehme ich sie ab
neunte Stunde Nachsitzen bei Herrn Weise
heute Parteiführung
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
drauf klicken oder ich bin hier für
immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an